[Music]
I've lived in Los Angeles for a while
now and I've gone I don't know if you've
noticed but gas stations dry cleaners
car washes they have headshots all over
the walls half the time I don't know
more than half the time I don't know who
anybody is on the wall well you asked us
because you were passionate about
finding out what's going on you said
could I you asked us if we could give
you the money to shoot a remote segment
oh yeah oh yeah I still don't got it
I've been living here in Los Angeles
about 16 years okay and I'm a comedian
okay
do you recognize me not off the bat no
I've noticed a lot of people on the
walls but I don't recognize the people
how do they end up on the wall well
usually if you're not that famous we put
you on the wall you're like the only
exception would be Bryan Cranston where
does this leave me how famous are you
you know like you don't know who I am
we could put you on the wall yeah Oh
usually that's how it goes if we don't
know you then you're good to go
let me know what you think is best I
have this one that says it's a girl not
a female
did you okay after looking at it yes but
I mean looking at could you tell us
female yeah but not for sure not 100%
yeah that's an older headshot preferably
we would use something more recent
can't really tell if that's you well you
don't even know who I am right so I
don't make it even harder where exactly
will be hanging I would say somewhere
around there thanks so much you're
welcome
[Music]
are there any qualifications that are
needed or no just if you have a headshot
you'll put it up right yes easy enough
this one yes what what sticks out just
the whole face the whole face and you
don't like it's a girl no one cuz you
have to advertise its you're a woman I
mean you could tell your breasts I don't
anymore
oh well here it does I know but I had a
double mastectomy
so that hole right there do you put me
in a hole oh yeah see the years would
stick out because of the frame and
everything that's even if they kept in
the frame if they kept it in the frame
they'd probably have to be a black frame
no it has to stay on the house it has to
stay in this frame if you're gonna be
difficult which I you clearly are
how do you decide who goes on your
headshot upon the gallery yeah all these
people you see up here they purchased
here so everybody on here cuz I saw a
monkey I saw a child and you're telling
me they purchased that's correct
what would I have to do to replace Loni
Anderson I don't really think there's
any replacing one he Anderson what is
she doing right now well she came in
recently and purchased some stuff is it
because she has a nicer rack than idea
that no it's not good no you both have a
nice rack but have you seen my rack no
but I'm you know I'm sure - no I just
had a double mastectomy well either way
it's nice I got friends at Sarah
Silverman did she come in here and buy I
can't pick she did not I'm gonna call
her oh hey it's TIG I am at universal
patio furniture and I walk in and who's
on the wall Sarah Silverman yeah you're
on this wall
do you remember Brant they just printed
out your your receipt you you paid four
hundred eighty five dollars and ten
cents for a double glider
so I think we shouldn't replace Sarah
with me yeah that's coming down
[Music]
you
[Applause]